nicole belloubet omission déminage au
palais de justice de nevers la réforme
de la justice prévoit la création d'un
tribunal judiciaire unique en fusionnant
instance et grande instance pour les
petits tribunaux une crainte être
marginalisés voire même perdre des sites
comme le tribunal d'instance de clamecy
pour la nièvre une perspective
écarté par la garde des sceaux ce qui
est important c'est qu'il y ait partout
en première instance une juridiction de
proximité
la justice est un élément essentiel pour
la vie de la république et donc jamais
nous n'avons imaginé fermé des tribunaux
jamais ça n'est pas compatible avec
l'idée que je me fais de la justice et
donc je le redis aucun tribunal ne sera
fermée
la ministre de la justice a promis au
personnel qu'il n'y aurait pas de
mobilité forcée mais la fusion des
juridictions et la dématérialisation
annoncée suscite encore des questions
on est plutôt rassuré mais quand même
la fusion des juridictions est prévue
pour le 1er janvier 2020
nous sommes en janvier 2019 ça va venir
très vite
et là quand même encore beaucoup de
choses à préciser et encore quand même
certaines inquiétudes qui vont encore
être on venir impacter les collègues à
nevers et partout en france les avocats
se sont également mobilisées contre ce
texte
avec la crainte pour les justiciables de
désert judiciaire ou de privatisation de
l'institution
s'ils ont eu quelques réponses le fond
de la réforme ne les convainc toujours
pas j'ai été rassuré uniquement ce qui
concerne la nièvre sur les implantations
des juridictions qui ne sont pas touchés
à temps vous avez très bien comme moi
que la réforme est toujours en cours et
les surprises sont toujours attendus
l'examen du texte par le parlement
devrait reprendre en deuxième lecture
dès la semaine prochaine s'il est voté
son entrée en vigueur est prévue pour le
1er janvier 2020